the eyes to the right
524
the nose to the left
43
the eyes to the right 524
the nose to the left 43 so the eyes have
it the eyes have it unlock
unlock means that that is the end of the
debate of course visual islam with me
stonking majority massive majority not
that surprising when you get both big
parties backing it this was by design i
mean the if you look at the motion so
carefully crafted intricately crafted to
get a majority of i mean nearly 500 481
just 43 saying no so uh you know that
would be some you know i'm going to
guess now
20 odd labour rebels probably a bit less
than that conservative you have the snp
a few
actually yeah quite a few abstentions we
know that some labour voter labour mps
uh have obviously been campaigning in
scotland and gone straight into the
conference one labour mp was getting
married we understand so a hundred not
uh i mean over 100 not returning
for this debate but a massive majority
exactly what the prime minister wanted
but in order to get that here's a
problem in order to get that majority
he needed to put forward a motion that
very carefully prescribed a uh
that the action would only be in iraq
firstly that they he would have to
return if he wanted the action in syria
uh and that there would be no combat
troops but then during the debate he
said oh by the way actually he's not
through in syria i i i believe that we
are justified for syria and actually i
believe the legal basis is already there
and labor
i don't know if labour were thrown by
that i don't know if that appeared in
the discussions of the telephone call we
know happened between the prime minister
and ed miliband but uh that is a fault
line that may return and one of the mps
actually asked him to clarify didn't
they because he didn't believe what he
was hearing no absolutely uh
he did have to clarify and david cameron
took well it has to be said that a prime
minister will always have executive
power over urgent military issues and
this convention that has emerged it's a
kind of it's in the backwash of what
happened in 2003 people are have wanted
a democratic grounding to foreign policy
um but there will always be occasions
where a prime minister has to act and it
might just be that the prime minister
wanted to hold back that and retain his
executive power